l'élément a priori dont sommes sûrs à ce
stade et qui est plutôt satisfaisant
c'est que la participation semble avoir
été supérieur dans le calvados à celle
de 2011 qui était basse relativement
basses dans la séquence historique mais
en tout état de cause je craignais et je
pense ne pas être avoir été la seule à
avoir une participation encore plus
encore plus faible or on a ou un mini je
sais pas comment il faut dire sursaut
c'est à dire une participation qui a été
finalement supérieure à celle de 2011
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'électeurs qui dans la dernière
ligne droite se sont mobilisés et sont
allés voter et ça en soit c'est une
bonne chose
on ne sait pas à qui profitera cette
partition et l'essentiel c'est déjà de
voter enfin je crois que dans la
démocratie l'essentiel c'est de voter
c'est d'aller s'exprimer
après nous sommes un pays libre et on
s'exprime quand on commet souhaite
est ce que le vote sanction et c'est une
réelle crainte encore à présent tous les
suffrages ne sont pas dépouillé mais le
vote sanction c'est un petit peu le lot
des élections intermédiaires si on prend
la séquence électorale des 20 dernières
années on voit bien que les élections
intermédiaires que ce soit celle de 2004
celle de 2008 celle de 2011 ont été des
élections intermédiaires gagnées par la
gauche soit de façon extrêmement forte
qu'en 2004 où en 2010 pour les pour les
élections régionales soit dans la
continuité de façon plus progressive
pour les élections les élections
cantonales donc je les élections
municipales donc je crois que ça fait
partie de l'expression de l'expression
des français et que ce soit la droite
entre 2002 2012 où la gauche
aujourd'hui il ya de la part des
électeurs une une sanction avec deux une
partie d'abstention une partie d'un vote
effectivement sanctions à l'égard de la
majorité qui exerce la responsabilité
dans le pays alors là ça fait partie du
fonctionnement de notre démocratie
les cantons étaient donc
redessinée redécouper 1/4 équilibrage
entre ville et campagne
est-ce que ça profitera d'une manière à
la gauche où ça moi je pense que c'est
pas le sujet je pense que ce qui est le
sujet c'est l'égalité du citoyen devant
la loi et quand on avait dans le
calvados un canton des cantons qui
faisait cinq mille habitants et même -
et d'autres qui faisait 27 mille
habitants sur l'agglomération caennaise
ça veut dire qu'il y avait un conseiller
général qui représentait dans un cas
27000 personnes dans un autre 5000 ça
veut dire que les citoyens n'étaient pas
traités de la même façon et ne pesait
pas de la même façon et ça en soit
d'ailleurs si il ya un principe
constitutionnel
ça n'était pas normal donc il fallait le
corriger et il fallait équilibrer la
représentation de chacun des deux chacun
des territoires
je crois que ça c'est une bonne une
bonne chose le deuxième élément très
positif c'est la parité on va voir au
conseil général la moitié d'hommes et la
moitié de femmes et pour l'expérience
qu'on en a et la part croissante
reprenne les femmes dans les conseils
municipaux dans les régions et y compris
de celles que je connais à l'assemblée
nationale je crois que c'est une chose
très importante que les femmes soient
présentes elles n'ont pas la même façon
de faire de la politique elles n'ont pas
les mêmes priorités
elles n'ont pas la même je lirai les
mêmes points d'attention et donc je
crois que ça c'est une bonne chose pour
la démocratie et pour la représentation
de la société
à quel niveau pourriez vous dire pour le
département pour la basse-normandie
on voit ça va on a évité le pire se
s'est pas de j'avais pas j'ai pas de
fixer de délai man 2 d'éléments de ce
type là il ya plutôt un raisonnement qui
tient à la représentation à la
représentation des territoires
c'est vrai que si on prend la situation
du calvados nous étions présents dans
l'agglomération caennaise
nous étions présents dans des cantons
qui représentait des villes je pense à
mes yeux je pense à falaise pense à
mézidon notamment c'est clair que là le
mode de scrutin élargi
élargie mieux quand on a des zones dites
zones rurales a un impact je pense que
c'est plutôt sur l'appréciation globale
de la représentation que nous pourrons
avoir une avoir une idée là en l'état
actuel nous ne sommes qu'au premier tour
et deuxièmement sur des résultats
partiels